تحديثات عسكريه مطلوبه بشكل عاجل لمعدات
الجيش الامريكي هي الاهم منذ قرن تقريبا
لموائمه التطورات ومواجهه التهديدات
المحتمله وفق موقع
1945 العسكري الاخباري البرنامج يشمل
تحديث نحو 34 نظاما تتركز اساسا على تعديل
قوه النيران ومداها كما نشاهد هنا لتصل ما
بين 70 و2000 كيلومتر لكن التعديل الاهم
يتمثل بتحديث اسطول القوات الامريكيه من
مدافع
ذاتيه الدفع التي نشرت لاول مره في
التسعينيات وتم الترقيتها عده مرات ويهدف
هذا البرنامج الى جعل هذه المدافع من عيار
155 اكثر دقه وقدره على الفتك عن طريق
جعلها محموله على شاحنات متحركه وذلك طبعا
بدلا من انظمه مدفعيه تقليديه تعتمد على
شاشات
مجنجره او شاسيهات مجزره كلفه اقل في
الانتاج وقدره على اداء المهام نفسها
وتستخدم انظمه المدفعيه تستخدم كاسلحه
للدعم القتالي وتوفر عاده النيران غير
المباشره ولكن اذا لزم الامر لديها ايضا
القدره على اطلاق النار مباشره ستلعب
المحموله على الشاحنات ادوارا مهمه في
المعارك الحديثه نظرا لسهوله حركتها عقب
اطلاق النار ثم الابتعاد فورا تجنبا
لنيران بطاريات المدفعيه المضاده وتتطلب
طبعا كما هو معلوم عددا اقل من الافراد
والمركبات الداعمه هنا وفقا لمواقع
امريكيه الاهميه القصوى تكمن في تزويد
فريق اللواء القتالي الثاني سترايكر
المتمركز في اوروبا بمدافع هاودزر
[موسيقى]